what's up gq i'm evan monk i'm eli brown
hi i'm thomas duterte and today we're
going undercover on the internet
it's actually actually nice
[Music]
i need more banter you guys aren't
saying i like to swear you guys are
allowed to swear in moderation okay
okay
imdb
[Music]
the reboot will contain more language
nudity and adult content than the
original due to airing on hbo max i
don't know how much we can say this
video is coming out after the show comes
out anyways right oh oh yeah well then
my first scene was a sex scene so
there we go first day on set ever and it
was a sex scene posted
twitter
how does one even go about making gossip
girl woke i mean it's definitely more
diverse this time around it's definitely
more diverse this time i think you're
gonna just have to see how it pans out
twitter i bet eli brown is going to be
the new dan they're all new characters
so oh he's his own man next
i'm really curious about the upcoming
gossip girl reboot hbo is planning the
state of teen dramas is very different
than it was back in mid-2000s will it go
the way of riverdale with absurd almost
surreal storylines in writing i've never
watched riverdale so i don't know that's
shady pretty honest what is
i've never watched riverdale i'm just
trying to start some like like teen
drama show beef
will there be any iconic references to
gossip girl one in the reboot i'm trying
to get josh to write in that meme that
was going around was like i have to pee
go piss girl
so hopefully that makes it in there
will instagram and twitter be your
social networks gossip girl it takes
place like right now so yeah there's a
lot of social media you would expect in
there
instagram
why you
wear manicure
i love to paint my nails sometimes it
just like makes your hands look prettier
me and eli painted each other's nails at
thanksgiving we did what's your favorite
color i love painting them yellow
over to cora
[Music]
will any characters from the original
gossip girl show be in the reboot and
same cast member reprise his or her role
i hope so that'd be fun
in the gospel girl reboot will a boy be
gossip girl yes maybe it'll evolve i
feel like it's either going to be meg
the stallion or precisely
[Laughter]
twitter so i tweeted crowning
achievement of my twenties just won a
battle royale on fortnite fair
said so will you quit acting to become a
gamer is that what you're trying to say
no no i love playing fortnite i just got
introduced to fortnite i'm not good
enough i'm not good enough at games
do you play fortnite i've never played
it in my life well you're not i don't
like being inside
can't really play video games outside
replied
twitter
i thought evan mark was just a male
i thought evan mark was just a model and
skateboarder who will they be in gossip
girl reboot
basically that exact same thing is what
you thought
evan mock's hand looking hurt maybe
because of a fight in the show between
the characters that's gossip girl all
caps i hurt my hand because i was
cooking tofu and i didn't drain all the
water out of the container
oil splashed everywhere and i had got a
third degree burn on my hand
and it doesn't feel good replied
instagram
the is your skincare routine
really don't have one honestly
moisturizer exfoliator
and just take a shower when you should
posted
instagram can you play cello
no i play guitar i play piano i play
bass a little bit i've been trying to
learn saxophone it's not easy
all right sexy sex man
next
[Music]
when is the wedding i don't know when is
we we're gonna go for a well i just
finished the rsvp it should be sent out
to all your contacts okay fantastic
we're still working out the details
we're getting married
yeah over zoom
[Laughter]
youtube
[Music]
where is the high fashion looks maybe i
am wrong please i wish where is the pea
coats and suits and fur coats
well
that screenshot is all raph simmons so i
guess it's fashion right minus the neck
guard face shield and the k 95.
i really hope it isn't as trashy as the
original gossip girl and it talks about
the real world issues and the topic of
social media and bullying and harassment
so much has changed since the original
it should address a lot of things that
have changed in the society i think this
actually nails it on the head that's
exactly that so you're not gonna be mad
at that next
quora
will that gossip girl 2021 reboot show
episodes and end xoxo gossip girl quotes
uh absolutely they're not going anywhere
is the gossip girl reboot worth watching
hell yes i mean
if you're typing this question you might
as well just watch it it's a lot easier
twitter
thomas dority can sing like sing sing i
did not know this holy sh
uh i can kind of sing i can like hold a
tune i'm not like a singer i've actually
started taking singing lessons getting
ready for broadway next
joe says can you give me acting tips
just be present as you can and just
react it's truthfully and honestly
okay guys that has been enough internet
for us today thank you for your
questions goodbye